bonsoir nous sommes le 2 juin 2015
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
journal de la rédaction dans l'actualité
au genre de issia ils ont une année pour
créer la cour la voiture de course du
futur course en cours lancée par renault
et dassault systèmes permettra aux
collégiens aux lycéens de monter une
véritable écurie de formule 1 une équipe
de magny les hameaux va disputer la
finale nationale demain la piscine à
vagues à l'île des loisirs attrapé fermé
cet été pour raisons de sécurité les
conséquences sur la fréquentation du
site et surtout quel sera son avenir les
réponses en plateau de jean-luc moreau
son président tout à l'heure et puis en
culture nous reviendrons sur le festival
du court-métrage des clayes-sous-bois
une vingtaine de films projetés samedi
et des lauréats désignés par un jury
professionnel marché 100 km pour dire
non aux violences sexuelles au congo
depuis est lundi le cyclotour traverse
trente et une ville des yvelines une
initiative lancée par la gerbe
association humanitaire chrétienne qui
entend notamment collecté des fonds
alors qu'en république démocratique du
congo plus de 200 mille femmes ont été
victimes de viol et de mutilations comme
arme de guerre depuis 1996 le 4 juin
pour le dernier jour du cyclo tour il
traversera le st gall st quentin en
yvelines avec une conférence débat à
versailles nous y reviendrons à cette
occasion le jour j c'est donc demain
pour les collégiens à manille quoi en
finale de course en cours créé en 2006
ce concours prêt permet donc à des
équipes de monter leur écurie de bolides
électriques de quoi familiariser les
jeunes élèves avec le monde de
l'industrie et des sciences nous avons
assisté au tout dernier à préparatifs de
ces événements le reportage de yolaine
autorisé de patrick jacques de dixmude à
la carrosserie et la peinture toute
neuve leur mini bolide électrique est
enfin prêt ces six élèves de 3e du
collège albert einstein de magny les
hameaux ont travaillé toute l'année pour
un projet qui se concrétisera demain
lors de la finale nationale du concours
course en cours il faut créer une
une petite écurie de formule 1 de mini
formule 1 donc on a des petites voitures
qui courent sur des pistes
donc on a fabriqué une petite piste pour
faire des essais donc on a déjà cette
partie là pfff il ya toute la partie
communication c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
aussi trouver ses sponsors parce que
tout et tout est autofinancé ça leur
apporte de l'autonomie surtout beaucoup
d'autonomie appuyé le d'être capable de
travailler en équipe
ces petites voitures sont créées à
partir d'un logiciel de conception
assistée par ordinateur ce qui fera la
différence demain c'est justement la
gestion de la programmation les voitures
en compétition ayant toutes le même
gabarit
après avoir gagné la finale régionale le
19 mai dernier
l'équipe était en plein rush ce midi
pour les derniers préparatifs
il nous reste quelques trucs à finir
mais sinon général oui on est prêts on
n'est pas stressés enfin moi non mais
les autres je sais pas encore on verra
ça sur place on avait eu plusieurs
problèmes pendant la régionale on qu'on
nous a appelés on n'y avait vraiment pas
cru alors je t'aimais mise à pleurer
alors là pour la nationale je sais pas
encore comment ça va gérer ce soir si
j'ai peur ou pas ce mini bolides porte
les traces de l'accident lors de la
finale régionale cassé en deux la fin de
la piste la voiture les a tout de même
qualifié pour demain une troisième aux
invités de ce mardi 2 juin jean-luc
moreau bonsoir bonsoir est le président
de lille de loisirs anciennement base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines si
tu fais donc à trappes en plateau ce
soir pour évoquer est tout d'abord cette
piscine à vagues qui va rester a fermé
cet été alors pourquoi cette fermeture
on parle de problèmes de sécurité sur ce
site alors c'est pas tant des problèmes
de sécurité que des problèmes techniques
mais qui ont une répercussion sur la
sécurité des baigneurs à savoir que déjà
depuis de nombreuses années cette
piscine présente des dysfonctionnements
du côté du carrelage sauf que là cette
année ces problèmes seront
considérablement augmenté et nous avons
constaté des
des infiltrations d'eau venant du sol
qui nous ont déjà d'ailleurs obligé
l'année dernière à renforcer les dose de
chlore dans la limite du raisonnable
mais pour que les baigneurs n'ait pas de
conséquences sur la qualité de l'eau et
là pendant l'hiver malheureusement on a
eu de nombreux et importants d'école
monde carnage donc il ya un expert qui a
été nommé par le tribunal
nous attendons ses conclusions fin juin
pas avant jeudi pas avant parce que
j'aurais préféré bien sûr les avoir
beaucoup plus tôt pour qu'on puisse
faire les travaux
si tenté qu'il soit faisable facilement
ça n'est pas le cas donc par principe de
précaution je dirais et pour la turquie
les 30 à 40000 baigneurs qui viennent
sur la piscine en été n'est pas de
problème à l'unanimité le comité
syndical l'unanimité moins une voix le
comité syndical a décidé de la fermeture
cet été donc dans la tente de ce rapport
d'expertisé dans la tente de savoir les
travaux qu'il faudra faire pour
justement ce rapport d'expertisé n'était
pas possible de le commander plutôt
d'avoir les résultats plutôt pour
permettre les travaux est ouverte et
ouvrir pour cet été pour ses vingt-cinq
mille à 40000 personnes qui viennent
chaque année
oui alors c'est sûr que sur le papier ça
aurait peut-être été possible sauf que
lorsqu'on est dans des contentieux qui
touchent des entreprises c'est une
entreprise contre une autre et cetera et
cetera
donc chacun sur ce renvoi un petit peu
d'abbas qui a déjà vu des travaux en
fait sur le site etc ces travaux là qui
sont aujourd'hui des mois est ce qu'il
ya eu ou non malfaçons sa création voilà
c'est tout le fond du problème il ya eu
des travaux je vais dire il ya eu des
rustines qui ont été mises dans ce
bassin ces travaux ont ils été
bien fait mal fait apparemment pas
complètement bien fait je suis très
présent dans mes propos et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu un expert nommé par le
tribunal c'est on en n'est plus non plus
si vous voulez une procédure d'avocats
contre avocat là c'est vraiment le
tribunal que nous avons saisi quand on a
vu que les deux les deux parties
n'arrivaient pas à s'entendre
on a saisi le tribunal et alors après on
se heurte au problème de délais
administratifs et c'est malheureusement
la conséquence d'avoir ce rapport que
fin juin
il se dit aussi qu'il ya un couperet au
dessus de cette piscine à vagues pour
voir éventuellement étudier la
possibilité d'une fermeture définitive
cette fois ci parce que cet incident qui
coûte cher le pierre bédier le président
du conseil départemental l'a dit
clairement c'est effectivement ce serait
une bonne chose pour faire des économies
que de la fermer le président de 50 ans
neeve il n'y a pas forcément opposé non
plus oui alors bon c'est sûr que c'est
tout le tout le monde est un peu
suspendue rapport de cet expert si les
travaux ne sont pas très importants on
pourrait envisager de la de la garder
ouverte mais avec un grand mais c'est
que il ya d'autres travaux très lourds à
venir il faut il faut savoir et puis
c'est un poker à l'entretien alors c'est
vous voilà enlevé de mai pour parce que
ces travaux non il n'y a pas accès
travaux il faut savoir que la région ile
de france a à peu près investi neuf
millions 9 millions d'euros sur les dix
dernières années et qu'il en faudrait
quasiment pas tout à fait autant mais
pas loin
pour arriver d'une carafe à refaire
complètement ce bassin et le dôme et le
dôme de la piscine qui je rappelle à 30
ans est donc aujourd'hui cette
installation en dehors de la partie
machinerie cette installation n'est plus
du tout aux normes et pose des problèmes
de sécurité
moi mon rôle en tant que président c'est
aussi assurer la sécurité des gens qui
vont venir dans la piscine et qui ne se
prennent pas quelque chose sur la tête
comme on vient de le voir sur quel qu'il
y ait quelques airs ya pas très
longtemps effectivement pour ceux qui
nous suivent en direct ce soir pour
cette fermeture justement aujourd'hui
est ce que ces actes et est-ce que déjà
vous l'avez dans un coin de votre tête
ou est-ce que encore tout est ouvert et
c'est possible de garder ce site ouvert
parce que ceux qui défendent cette
piscine à vagues vont vous dire que ça
un rôle social on disait tout à l'heure
25 mille quarante mille personnes qui
viennent ce sont des gens qui le plus
souvent ne partent pas en vacances qui
ont accès donc à ce site pour
coût réduit la ferme et c'est une
possibilité alors c'est bien avancé le
rôle le rôle social et n'est pas
contestable ça là dessus je pense que
tout le monde en est conscient que ce
soit à temps ou conseiller départemental
qu'à la casse qui est bien sûr nous
mêmes donc mais ce rôle social
effectivement il arrivait un coup
aujourd'hui ses toutous baigneurs qui
rentre dans cette piscine a un coût et
malheureusement ce coût est plus
important que les recettes et les coûts
de combien d'années les cénacles
justement c'est à dire en coûts
d'entretien abba grosse grosso modo vous
comptez entre 1 euro et 1 euro 50 par
baigneur qui rentrent qui rentre dans sa
tombe dans cette piscine en termes de
déficit alors la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de vous savez gérer au
quotidien c'est une chose se projeter
dans le futur centre de santé en est une
autre
et si le rapport de l'expert nous dit il
faut faire des travaux importants sur le
bas sur le bassin là il est certain
qu'avec nos partenaires on recherchera
une autre solution parce qu'on on pourra
pas continuer à investir et je pense pas
que la région ile-de-france ce le soit
sur d'accord aussi on pourra pas
continuer à investir des millions
d'euros comme ça à fond perdu
si on n'a pas une garantie de la
pérennité principalement du bassin mais
mais mais des années que c'est aussi la
base de loisirs l'île des loisirs que
généralement c'est un équipement un
ensemble qui coûte relativement cher
dans son entretien au quotidien est ce
qu'il ya des économies qui sont prévues
c'est la question que je vous poserai
juste après ce micro-trottoir
fréquentez-vous cette île des loisirs
cette base de loisirs vos réponses tout
tout est bien tout est propre
le centre équestre à côté donc il ya
quand même pas mal d'activités donc je
trouve ça très bien pour les enfants
j'habite dans les yvelines depuis plus
de trente ans donc
mais j'avais l'occasion pour l'instant
niel et puis pas forcément le temps que
j'habite pas forcément sur la ici donc
c'est un peu ça fait un peu de chemin
pour y aller à un peu tout va il fait
bon faire des barbecues famille comme
tout le monde
faire le tour le premier au pied puis
péché voilà prêt à aider un groupe de
copains on va faire la pêche à bompas la
journée
quand j allais je faisais des pique
niques et barbecue tout et on s'était
posé souvent pour les hommes et les
petits quoi c'est tout et c'est devenu
en ayant enfin cette île des loisirs
aujourd'hui elle est appréciée par ceux
qui la fréquentent tout le monde me va
pas s qu'à une politique qui est
développée aussi pour attirer les gens
on va faire venir la faire vivre oui
alors c'est ça c'est un des problèmes
principaux que nous avons sur les
loisirs aujourd'hui grosso modo l'île de
loisirs c'est 70% de saint quentinois et
donc dont beaucoup de gens habitant
entre ap montigny et guyancourt et avec
comme il a été dit dans ce micro
trottoir une forte activité de barbecue
de dimanche
donc on va le samedi ou le dimanche donc
mais tout ceci si vous voulez est
complètement soumis à la météo si la
météo et est agréable et bien on a
beaucoup de fréquentation est bien sûr
donc inverse
ça n'est pas le cas exemple la piscine
en temps normal on a quarante mille
entrées l'année dernière nous avons eu
22 je vous dis ça de mémoire 22000
entrer parce qu'on a été obligés dessus
sur deux mois de temps on a fermé en
tout plus de huit jours
donc vous voyez qu'on est on est soumis
à des contraintes météo et - aujourd'hui
la vision que j'ai sur le sur le futur
c'est d'arriver à développer des
activités qu'ils ne soient plus
contraintes qui ne soit plus soumise à
eauze allait météo
donc on a des projets sur la partie nord
de la base de loisirs puisqu'on a la
chance d'avoir 70 hectares aujourd'hui
qui qui sont en zone agricole mais
temporaire donc on est en train de
réfléchir sur des projets pour voir
comment peut-on compléter les activités
d'eacl chaque base de loisirs ça sera
obligatoirement des activités des
activités couvertes je moi je veux
entendre président tant que je serai
président je ne peux pas imaginer qu'on
présente un projet qui soit complètement
à l'air libre avec les conséquences
qu'on a pour la piscine je vous rappelle
on n'ouvre que sur juillet août sur le
fonctionnement global monde cette île de
loisirs base de loisirs il va y avoir
aussi une augmentation du tarif d'entrée
ou en tout cas auparavant c'était
l'accès gratuit pour ceux qui
disposaient d'une carte qui habitait
saint quentin en yvelines
les élèves de monde de cette carte oui
pour accéder en voiture en véhicule sur
le site maintenant ce sera trois fois
maximum par an alors effectivement à
compter du 1er octobre et ensuite à
partir du 1er janvier il y aura un accès
illimité à 3-3 accès gratuit par an mais
on n'a pas forcément être très populaire
ça ne va pas être très populaire mais
vous savez aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'argent public sans poches privées
je crois qu'il faut il faut en être
conscient on l'a vu dans d'autres
instances
donc à un moment donné il faut faire il
faut faire le point et voir qu'est ce
qu'on peut proposer comme formule
d'abonnement qui permettrait aux saint
quentinois
j'irai élargi parce que n'oublions pas
que au 1er janvier le périmètre de
l'agglomération va être élargie remplace
dans le rôle c'est aussi de prévoir ce
futur là et de voir quelle forme de
tarifs on va pouvoir mettre en place
pour accueillir aussi les la population
des cinq communes qui vont rejoindre qui
vont rejoindre la casse qui ça pourrait
coûter au pays ça va être un des
forfaits ça pourrait coûter combien bas
ça sera ça sera à ce sera un abonnement
alors vous me recevez un jour trop tôt
si je puis dire puisque j'ai demain le
comité d'administration de l'île de
loisirs et ce sujet va être abordé donc
vous me permettrait de garder
reviendront leurs émotions voilà aux
élus qui composent ce comité on imagine
ce sera raisonnable parce que les
familles qui suivent ce show me suivre
donc se poser aussi la question oui ils
ont raison d'y aller
non mais il faut il faut qu'on soit dans
une formule
raisonnable parce qu'on est parfaitement
conscient et u6 me pas remis en cause de
ce côté accueil grand public de ce côté
social cas aujourd'hui
la base de loisirs alors bon soyons
aussi claire sur la partie piscine
qu'avec comme je discutais l'autre jour
avec le maire de trappes
quelque part j'ai pas dire qu'il est
très content mais il va pouvoir
accueillir sur trappe qui a la chance
d'avoir maintenant une très belle
piscine toute la partie j'irai de gens
qui aujourd'hui venez sur la base de
loisirs il ya la piscine de montigny
aussi donc voix celle de maurepas qui a
fermé alors est celle de maurepas qui
est fermé on n'a vraiment pas de chance
cette année il ya de fermeture ça c'est
vrai que c'est un problème juste pour
conclure est ce qu'il y aura des
activités malgré tout autour de ce site
pour cet été oui alors ça si vous voulez
c'est le sait le sait le poids important
aujourd'hui toute l'équipe d'animation
est en train de finaliser des activités
nouvelles qu'on va mettre principalement
en place sur sur des jeux de sable et
sur des jeux d'eau également puisque n'y
aura par exemple un toboggan qui va
arriver dans une piscine aérienne même
un petit à petit un petit bassin mais
c'est sûr que c'est les il faut lui faut
se mettre à la place aussi des agents
qui travaillent sur sur le sur le sur la
piscine fermée pour eux ça a été c'est
vraiment un crève coeur donc ils ont
aujourd'hui le plus grand ils accordent
le plus grand intérêt à mettre en place
des activités de telle sorte à ce que on
comprend son mieux je vais pas dire
qu'on va compenser complètement mais
qu'on compense au mieux ce qu'on ne
pourra pas assurer avec l'ouverture de
la piscine donc à proposer des activités
aux saint quentinois et ce alentours qui
se rendent régulièrement et notamment
pendant l'été sur ceux-ci absolument
merci à jean luc rambaud président de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines puis nous reviendrons sur cette
tarification puisque vous les annoncera
demain
depuis samedi les trappistes sont
appelés à voter pour renouveler leurs
neuf comités de quartiers jusqu'à
vendredi un bureau de vote mobiles se
déplace dans différents lieux de la
commune mélanie poker et william elles
s'y sont rendus
une simple carte d'identité pour prouver
que vous êtes majeur et trappistes et
vous pouvez voter pour votre comité de
quartier l'importance des comités de
quartier justement c'est permettre à
l'allemagne une démocratie de proximité
effectif quelque chose qui marche qui
parle aux gens le but c'est de
rapprocher rapprocher les gens dans les
quartiers crée aussi une synergie entre
quartiers ce qui est très important
permettre aussi aux gens de pouvoir
s'exprimer de faire remonter également
les dysfonctionnements à la mairie de
parler ce qui va mal mais aussi ce qui
va bien sûr les quartiers sur trapil
yanev comité élu pour trois ans
composé d'élus du quartier de
conseillers municipaux et de
représentants du tissu associatif
commerçants ou autre ces comités se
rassemblent une fois par mois pour
participer à la vie de la commune je
pense que la ville a besoin de beaucoup
de gens
beaucoup de gens doivent se mobiliser
pour cette ville
donc je tiens
participer au dynamisme de la ville
le bureau de vote mobiles se déplace
jusqu'au vendredi 5 juin un bureau fixe
se tiendra le samedi 6 juin
il ne manque que votre contribution
jusqu'au 7 juin se déroule la quinzaine
régionale de la sécurité routière à
travers plusieurs opérations la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique des yvelines sensibilise à la
protection des usagers un atelier et sur
la thématique des piétons vient d'être
organisée à versailles hall n 13 et
william l vous êtes sur le bon ben là
sur le trottoir vous fait des dérapages
vous traversez là bas les pieds sur le
presque sur le guidon tranquille pour
nouvelle pin sécurité vous mettez les
autres en danger non d'accord ce jour là
sur la place du marché de versailles
pas de sanction juste de la prévention
dans le cadre de la quinzaine de la
sécurité routière une opération de
sensibilisation était organisée hier
objectif repérer des piétons qui ont des
comportements dangereux dans les esprits
on va penser que le piéton est
prioritaire
malheureusement il faut bien comprendre
que dans le rapport poids puissance est
toujours le piéton qui va perdre
j'ai rarement vu un téton s'en sortir
avec ce soit l'automobiliste qui soit
vraiment baissé ce que je veux dire en
cas de collision sur cette zone de
sécurité publique et des yvelines
huit piétons ont trouvé la mort sur les
28 personnes tuées sur la route l'année
dernière c'est moins qu'en 2013 avec
eddy piétons sur 31 tués
il traverse à des endroits où ils ne
devraient pas ils sont distraits par
leur téléphone portable ou leur musique
dans les écouteurs les piétons ne sont
pas exempts des comportements à risque y
des problèmes d'alcool ou de stupéfiants
pourtant la seule sanction qu'un piéton
en cours est une amende de 4 euros
or ça existe sachez le mais ça n'a pas
forcément une valeur suffisamment
pédagogique pour marquer les esprits du
piéton qui aura traversé là où il
n'aurait pas dû le faire se mettant
lui-même en danger et puis aussi
provocant un danger pour les autres
usagers de la route puisque on s'en
doute bien que quand on conduit soit son
véhicule soit sa moto de manière tout à
fait normale
un piéton vient de se jeter sous vos
roues que vous veniez a percuté un
piéton que s'ils traversent n'importe où
c'est également extrêmement traumatisant
chapeau au niveau de la demande mais la
demande est tellement minime pour les
piétons 4 euros risquent pas d'être
dissuasif
par contre 735 si on a engagé pour la
voiture si on engage et au passage
piéton qui respectent pas mais bon faut
les arrêter fauqué la police à ce moment
là donc aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la
quinzaine de la sécurité routière pour
une opération alternative à la sanction
je vous ai proposé vous êtes sans qu'il
ait de venir ici est prêté un petit
parapet drague
hier la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique
arrêter aussi des usagers de la route
comportements dangereux en 2015 dans
l'ensemble du département des yvelines
au 12 mai déjà 14 tués dont trois
piétons culture la quatrième édition du
festival les clés du cinéma se tenait
samedi dernier à l'espace philippe
noiret aux clayes-sous-bois retour sur
cet événement sur son palmarès avec
sephora namani nom court métrage de
moins de 16 minutes trois heures de
projection un public local fidèle et un
jury de professionnels voici la recette
gagnante des clés du cinéma créer des
rencontres entre professionnels et faire
découvrir le court métrage au public tel
était l'enjeu samedi dernier de la
quatrième édition de ce festival aux
clayes-sous-bois le festival de la vente
à ceux qui ont créé leur rencontre entre
un public et le réalisateur qui a envie
de montrer son film n'a le plaisir
toujours d'avant public des clés et qui
vient voir des films qui viennent
d'ailleurs et puis également les
activités culturelles de leur ont dit
que les banlieues sont des déserts
artistique il ce pasteur désert culturel
voici le contre exemple de ce qu'on peut
faire dans une dans une huile de la
périphérie de paris
le jury professionnel a décerné sipri à
la fin de cette compétition
en choisissant de mettre à l'honneur
pour la première place
la momie en court métrage jugée très
positive
cette humanité qu'on finit par ne plus
voir dont le sucre se trouve là tous les
soirs au fond de cette boîte
toi qui pensaient que je ne travaillerai
jamais
je suis assez surpris en fait parce que
je trouve que le niveau de la
compétition était un été très très bon
et puis la bd bien évidemment ça me fait
ça me fait super plaisir
en tout cas ça m'encourage à continuer à
faire faire d'autres films
le lauréat du festival verra son
prochain film produit par if i musici
société de production du parrain de
cette quatrième édition
manifestement très satisfait du choix du
jury
c'est un choix qui je pense rentrer dans
un jour suis même certain qu'ils
rentrent dans dans la ligne de ce que
j'aime défendre avec un sujet assez
original et une esthétique qui as est
assez forte donc
donc c'est très très encourageant et du
coup je serai ravi de rencontrer ce
réalisateur pour voir si des projets
peuvent émerger lancement j'écris un
article et sinon je fais des corrections
par des guides de voyage pour arrondir
mes fins de mois c'est intéressant ça
brille c'est pour çà français c'est
l'invitation au voyage vous voyez
lors de ce festival tv fil 78 également
remis un prix appartements à vendre
l'histoire d'une vengeance d'un agent
immobilier a été récompensé en voici un
extrait d'abord le regard
après les oreilles cela fonctionne dans
ce sens et pas dans un autre
avec vous j'ai fonctionné pareil qu'avec
un couple j'ai commencé par la cuisine
la salle de bain la salle à manger pour
finir par les chambres je pensais à
juste titre d'ailleurs que le côté
fonctionnel de l'appartement était plus
important appartements à vendre l
intégralité de ses différents courts
métrages inscrits au festival seront
bientôt à découvrir sur notre antenne
nous en parlions hier pendant trois mois
le zoo de thoiry va accueillir d'une
nouvelle espèce animale 16 dinosaures
plus vrai que nature sont installés dans
le parc depuis ce week-end petit voyage
dans la préhistoire avec catherine je
l'attends pas forcément très aimable non
vous n'êtes pas jurassic park mais dans
la nouvelle animation proposée par le
zoo de thoiry bienvenue un brachiosaure
tyrannosaures et autres tricératops ces
animaux animés ont été conçus aux états
unis leur réalisation basé sur des
fossiles de dinosaures et sur les
connaissances existantes de
paléontologues
tout cela est très sérieux les
caractéristiques et proportion était
respecté autant que possible certains
d'entre eux pèsent plusieurs tonnes et
mesure près d'une dizaine de mètres
ce sont des animatronics donc des
dinosaures articulé qui font du bruit
certains même crash de l'eau pouvait
voir ça derrière moi
et il bouge ils ont les yeux qui
regardent des visiteurs et on les a
installés côté vrais animaux dans des
très beaux enclos paysager et qui sont
installés dans le jardin zoologique
une animation à retrouver jusqu'à la fin
du mois d'août inclus dans le prix du
billet d'entrée l'équipe pédagogique
propose également des ateliers autour de
ce thème pour comprendre par exemple
pourquoi les dinosaures ont disparu
attention en tout cas ne pas se faire
mordre cela peut avoir de drôles de
conscience
c'est la fin du journal je vous retrouve
demain aux mêmes horaires bonne soirée
sur téléphiles dans un instant le 7-8
politique